a lot of fans mailed Ronnie spoons to
spoon his [ __ ] out so he doesn't appeal
so it's a package of four of them with a
note saying I got the note here right
here actually hi Ronnie
use this for your brick turds in the
future from curtains who ever [ __ ]
curtains 'as well nice I heard John Hein
went through it somehow oh yeah yes I
had the same a similar issue as to
Ronnie what did you do yeah what'd you
do John I went to a local health care
place and I said I need help they put me
in an ambulance
and they took me to a hospital I went
into triage and there's people with you
know bleeding everywhere and I'm just
sitting there like I can't you know
hoping to get this out they rolled me on
my side and try to get it out and it
didn't work
doctor hand up you're ready stick their
hand in there Wow and then a doctor came
in and tried to help the nurse and that
didn't happen Wow they gave me an enema
they're like go into the bathroom and
try this and I did and with all the
water up there that managed to get it
out dislodge it look at Ronnie laughing
at you let me tell you the feeling of
that coming out of you is the greatest
feeling it was a huge it was pretty big
it was like you know maybe the size of
my fist like it could not fit out at all
but the toughest part with Ronnie why
are you laughing at John cuz look at
what he went through he had to go to a
urgent care first then put him in an
ambulance then gotta go to the hospital
then they try to pull it out and it
didn't work now how long did this were
you suffering with this hours yeah see I
went in within a half-hour dude but
Ronnie I was better I went to sleep
after that like a baby Ronnie I
medical professionals helping me because
of the threat of a heart attack or
whatever else and the last thing I would
do is even though I know desperate times
call for desperate measures is to take
my hand and stick it up my ass and try
to bring the crap out of it that to me
like I was pushing as hard as I could
John can I give you some advice son why
don't you write a book about this
instead of a old TV show the way in go
ahead run haul it jump the turd instead
of go to that clinic you gotta try one
of these see this this is the starter
spoon for when you got [ __ ] up your ass
blow and then there's this spoon this is
the heavy-duty spoon open
you